OK, we have a voicemail number and that number
is two one nine two David P..
You can call absolutely anytime that you would
like.
Here's a caller from Hawaii who get some of
the numbers wrong, but still makes a good
point.
Let's take a listen.
David, this is one out in Hawaii among the
big island of Hawaii, right?
June 17th to 2020.
We haven't had a case of Corona virus in days,
maybe weeks.
So that's not true.
In fact, if you look at the numbers, you see
that Hawaii has had new cases every single
day, but very, very few, very, very few.
And yet when I go out and I drive around and
I go to public places, people are wearing
masks.
We have no cases.
All right, island.
And people are following protocol.
People are making sure to keep.
Six foot distance.
So when I see reports of Texas and Arizona
people pretending that there's no virus, right.
I really can't understand why.
And it makes me so happy that I decided to
move to an island in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean.
Understood.
I think we've got cut off there.
I totally get the feeling.
Listen, I'm not in an aisle on an island in
Massachusetts, but I am.
I'm also very glad that I'm here and not in,
you know, Texas or as Arizona or Florida or
wherever else.
So Hawaii does have some cases.
I was just looking at the numbers before coming
on on air.
But they are very few.
They've managed it very, very well.
And people listen that the guidelines work.
That's the reality.
The guidelines work.
And you can say what you want about death
rates or mortality or age or any of this other
stuff.
The guidelines work and you've got to stick
to them.
And just having the guidelines, is it enough?
You actually need Buy-In from people to do
the things that you are asking them to do.
And my fear is I take no pleasure in this
because any death is a death.
It's all horrible.
My fear is that what we're going to see in
some of these states that have decided we're
just not shutting down, it's just not happening.
No matter what happens, we may be seeing things
that are even worse than anything we've seen
so far in some of these states, upcoming increasingly
increasing warnings about ICU and hospital
capacity being stressed to the absolute max.
In some states, it's bad.
And the question will be, will it start to
bleed over into the states that are doing
the right things because of interstate travel?
We don't know.
We're going to watch all of this stuff very,
very closely.
OK.
We have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
Get the bonus show by becoming a member at
join Pacman, dot com or patrie on dot com
slash David Pakman show.
And remember that the daily audio podcast
is always available if you watch on YouTube
or Facebook clips and you would rather just
get the full hour audio podcast, it's available
for free on iTunes, Stitcher, Google Play,
podcasts, Spotify, Pandora.
It's almost too available.
It's too easy to get the audio podcast.
Subscribe to it for free and get The Daily
Show every single day.